and arvindan who's here in the audience
um i'm going to talk about certain
aspects of
density composition um
we've seen tensors uh and their
applications
in several talks on the first day i'll
remind you about
some of these things so there'll be a
little bit of a little bit of repetition
so the origins of all this goes back to
factor analysis which is a very common
way to analyze data
let's say you arrange
data about how how much people like
movies in the matrix
famous netflix matrix or you look at
students and test scores
and somehow there is a there's a belief
that this matrices like these even
though they're very large
have some kind of uh sparse or simple
explanation
and one kind of simple explanation
that's very popular
is a low rank decomposition
so if we could somehow decompose this
matrix
as a sum of rank one terms then
the belief is that there is some meaning
in these rank one term so it's useful to
try to look for such
low rank decompositions
now one problem with this this approach
is that
in general there could be many
decompositions
you'd like to find a meaningful one in
some cases a meaningful one
uh is one that is non-negative in some
cases a meaningful one is one that is
sparse and so on and so forth
okay so you have some data which somehow
is a rank
sum of you believe is a sum of small
number of rank one terms
and we'd like to find what these terms
are because hopefully they give us some
insight into what the data is about
now one problem with doing this with
matrices is that unless we
impose any further constraints on these
factors
any suitable rotation of these vectors
will also give you
a low rank decomposition so you know if
i have
a b transpose i can insert rotation
matrices q q inverse
and i also get an equivalent
decomposition okay
so somehow i in order for this to be
meaningful
it should be the case that this
decomposition is unique in some sense
otherwise there's no way in which i
could uh distinguish
uh you know there's no way in which i i
know which which one is the right one
okay so how do you know that you found
the desired decomposition it would be
nice to have some kind of uniqueness
profit
um so in statistics people realized this
a long time ago that you know when you
work with matrices and lower
anti-compositions
you have this so-called rotation problem
um and
so one way to get around this kind of
rotation problem is to
turn your attention to higher dimensions
so just as
you talk about decomposition of two
dimensional arrays of numbers
matrices we also talk about
decompositions of higher dimensional
arrays of numbers
cancers and such tensors arise in many
situations
you could for example look at some
variables and represent high order
correlations
as a tensor partial derivatives etc etc
um so for example a three-dimensional
tensor is just a collection of
one-dimensional matrix slices so each of
these
is just a matrix right so you have a
collection of these matrices stacked
together
now just as we talked about low rank
decompositions of
matrices we could also talk about low
rank decomposition of tensors
right in this case a rank one tensor
is just x or y denser z it's uh
if x y and z are n dimensional vectors
and this is a
n by n by n array where the i j
k th entry is the product of the ith
entry of x the jth entry of
y and the kth entry of z right
and again we could hope to take a tensor
given to us
and express it as a sum of a few
rank one terms just as we did with
matrices and the smallest such
is called the rank now uh
here's the amazing thing that was proved
by kruskal
uh in 1977. he showed that under certain
conditions and i'll actually make this
precise a little later uh
density competition is unique so
any way of writing this tensor as
a sum of our rank one terms
must essentially be the same up to
permutation and scaling
and this is different fundamentally
different from the matrix case
where we have this rotation problem the
spell by the way for the people in
computer science
um it's the same kruskal who did
spanning tree
uh turns out he was he was actually a
statistician
the spanning tree work was done very
early in his career but most of his
career was
uh as a statistician and this was
some of the work he did which has now
become a seminal result in the tensor
literature
so i'll tell you what these rank
conditions are in a little bit
but the take-home message is that
somehow if you look for low rank
decompositions of these
higher higher order objects
you have uniqueness and you don't have
this in the matrix
okay so you know this this result
really uh paved the way for a lot of
applications of tensory compositions in
a number of fields that i don't i know
very little about
but i do know that uh tensor analysis is
used frequently in the psychometrics
literature the chemometrics
which are algebraic statistics and so on
so forth
one way in which this uniqueness has
been exploited
is to show that if you have
some kind of hidden variable model and
again we've seen a bunch of these
in various talks on the first day we'll
see some more
i'll remind you about some of these
later in the talk but right now at a
very abstract level
you have some kind of hidden model
that's producing data
okay we'd like to figure out what this
model is we have to
figure out what the parameters of this
model is and
one recipe in order to do this is
you somehow compute a tensor you you
observe the data
from the data you produce a tensor
such that there is a low rank
decomposition of this tensor
if you knew that low rank decomposition
you would be able to recover the
parameters of the underlying model
okay and now you appeal to uniqueness to
say that well this laurentide
composition is
is unique so in fact this implies
that these models are identifiable
yeah so he really introduced this method
of moments right
but he was looking at two more stairwise
moments
but it's the same thing so uh whenever
you use typically when you use tensors
you
compute some kind of higher order
moments and then
you say that well there is a correct
decomposition of this tensor
in as a sum of a small number of terms
and this is basically unique so it is it
is an instance of
uh this method of moments that was
initiated by pearson
okay all right so
uh you know a result of almond matthias
rhodes uses exactly this framework
and argues that because of um uniqueness
various models are identifiable
okay and there are also algorithms due
to anema and
collaborators uh over several papers
where
they've used this framework to actually
design algorithms
that prove that certain learning
problems are tractable and very
different regimes from what we used to
know before
for example mixture of gaussians and so
on so forth so this gives us a new range
of
tractable problems in the learning
method they're all based on this
paradigm that you compute a certain
tensor
this tensor encodes these parameters and
now you find a lower angle composition
so that's the general recipe in which
these tensor decompositions have been
used
okay let me tell you a little bit about
you know this uniqueness result
what are the conditions and so on so
forth so let's say we have this tensor
it's a sum
it's a three tensor it's a sum of
r terms um we could write down
each of these vectors a a1
a1 a2 a3 stack them together as
the column vectors of a matrix a and
similarly for b
and similarly for c okay so when i say t
is abc what i mean is that
t is the product of the column vectors
of a b and c in this way
okay all right so each of these
a b c are n by r matrices
sorry t is the stacking of the vector
no no when i say this notation i'm not
really going to use this notation very
much but when i
when i use this notation i mean that
this tensor
is obtained from abc in this way okay
okay that's what i mean all right
so so what chris carl said uh is that
under certain rank conditions
on these matrices a b and c this
decomposition is unique
okay so in order to describe what these
rank conditions are
i need to introduce a certain notion
um so before i say that of course this
uniqueness is up to permutation and
scaling
so you know there's nothing special
about the first term there's nothing
special about the second term and so on
so forth i could
obviously permute them and of course i
can also individually multiply
the a b and c by scalar so that the
scalar is multiplied to one
okay all right so um
so this uniqueness is defined in terms
of a certain parameter that
is called the kruskal rank what is the
cross call rank it's the following
given a matrix a look at the largest
k for which every k subset of the
columns of a is linearly independent
okay and the largest such k is called
the crystal rank
of this
all right so this is a stronger notion
than rank right
rank just needs one subset one large
subset that's linearly independent this
is that every subset
is linearly independent uh and they're
somewhat reminiscent of the strict
isometry either not quite
it has a flavor of mystical example
okay so now having defined the crystal
rank
uh the theorem that kriskal proved is
that
if the rank is small enough it satisfies
this condition
2r plus 2 is less than equal to the sum
of the crystal ranks of a b
and c then uh
the decomposition is unique okay so
you know one case you should think about
is if a b
and c are full rank they have ranked as
large as possible
n right crystalline cannot be larger
than n
then uh the composition is unique up to
rank up to
roughly three n over two
and there are generalizations of these
two high order tensors as well
roughly speaking uh if you look at the
statement for
higher order tensors you have the sum of
the kuskal ranks
on the left hand side on the right hand
side you again you have 2r
plus some term which is linear in the
in the back of the tensor just for
context most tensors have productive
yes yes good point so not as nandy
points out
most tensors in fact have quadratic line
uh and i'll actually refer to some
results about
uh that are sort of related to this by
some counting or something you should
you can show that uh
it's usually unique like if you take a
random
310 the rank is usually unique or is
good question so so so two results right
one is that
typically tensors have rank which is
quadratic
right three tensor and secondly what can
we say about uniqueness of typical
tensors
okay so usually the notion of typical
that's used is this generic notion
so you say that if your tensor is such
that
um you know all of the values don't lie
on any
lower dimensional manifold don't satisfy
any algebraic condition and so on so
forth then what can you say about the
rank of this tensor
it's known that uh under this generic
condition
uh density composition for three times
is unique
up to something like n square over 16.
okay so if you choose so if you choose a
random not a random three tensor but a
random sum of
n squared over 16 rank one tensor then
it will that will be the only
decomposition
yes yes that'll be the only composition
exactly
okay
computing this yes we don't know how to
certify or compute or prove bounds on
chris colorand
and you know again it's very reminiscent
of
isometry
yes so very it's very similar and we
have the same difficulties over here
okay yeah is it easy to see that it
doesn't matter whether you look at a b
or c because of c no
i mean the crystal rank of a b and c can
be very different right
because
there's no connection between i mean a b
and c are arbitrary columns
column vectors the tensor is just the
sum of the tensor products of the eighth
column of a the eighth column of b and i
column c but a priority there's no
connection between a b and c
it could be the case that a and b have
high rank
and c happens to have a very low crystal
right in fact we'll talk about
such situations in a bit okay yeah so
just
a remark on the generic case
i think what's expected most of the time
for generic
as it's not unique but if you just do
generic minus one
then it is expected to be unique but not
known
i see i see so the bound n square of 16
is not
it could actually potentially be much
larger well
up to three
or two or whatever it is okay but that's
just what's expected not quite snow so
i just wanted to make sure that but for
generally not being unique that's
pretty much understood so so in generic
uh up to certain vancouver it is like
choosing
our random one things and summing them
up right someone who doesn't like you
can easily find one that's not unique
yes of that under any given rank but if
you choose like a random one
thing then um up to one less than the
maximum one
it will likely be unique or believed
that it's believed to be unique
and known to be unique up to whatever
georgios should know the exact
tickets well i think this belief is
proved that
the product of the factor is bounded by
10 and power 5 so quite a lot
if the product of a factor is the
product of
yes of the sides of the uh but he he's
doing n by n by n
so yeah yeah pretty large oh so in this
case
yeah i see so for large enough you
actually can prove that there is unique
they're small enough for small enough oh
for smaller okay
all right good uh i'm hoping to learn as
much from the audience as i
hope to convey to you in the end so
what's this one one thing i mean
the rank is also very closely related to
error correcting codes right very
correct that's the position that you
want from the parity check matrix
if it's not really it was finally
yeah question other questions comments
all right so this is kruskal's condition
and uh
as we've said you know in the in the
generic case we expect this
bound for uniqueness to be much higher
and we know that that's the case
all right so let's take a step back and
let's remind ourselves
where we were using tensor decomposition
you remember this recipe that that i
said uh you know we have some kind of
hidden
latent variable model it's producing
data we have some way in which we can
compute a tensor such that
a low rank decomposition of this tensor
somehow encodes
the parameters of the model we compute
this tensor from the data that we have
and then we appeal to uniqueness and say
ah we're done
okay this is identifiable
now let's not worry about algorithms for
a second let's just talk about the
identifiability aspect
one issue that you have when you try to
apply density compositions in this
in this way is that you don't really
have access to the real
tensor which is the real
moment tensor or whatever it is that you
were trying to compute right
you only have uh approximation you have
an empirical approximation based on the
data
so whatever whatever tensor you're
trying to decompose
you have a estimate of the tensor but
not the exact answer
now crystal's result does not really
apply in this case
so technically speaking kryskal's result
just says uh
you know if you have the exact answer
then in fact becomes a unique we have
this theorem doesn't say anything about
errors
okay now from the point of view
identifiability this is fine basically
identify everybody says that
you know with access to potentially
infinite number of samples you can
basically identify the parameters
but from the point of view of
understanding how many samples you
really need is it polynomial is this
exponential
unfortunately this doesn't say anything
okay
so um you know our first foray into
tensor decompositions was motivated by
trying to understand this issue
is it possible to come up with a robust
version
of kruskal's uniqueness theorem by
robust i mean
uh one that can handle errors okay so
that's what we did
uh in a result with the other thin then
um we showed that we basically gave a
robust analog of crystals exactly the
same result
where now we're not given the tensor
exactly we're given the tensor
with up to some error we can recover
the um the factors a b and c
up to some other error if
the sum of the crystal ranks satisfy the
rank condition
okay now we need to change things a
little bit
uh you know the input error and the
output error are polynomially related
now our notion of crystal rank has to be
some sort of robust
analog of crystal rank right for kryskal
rank we require that every k columns are
linearly independent
uh now that's a very weak notion right
they could just barely be linearly
independent that's not good enough
what we need is that every k columns we
look at that matrix that has condition
number that's
bounded by tau so we need to be able to
bound the condition number of
every k columns
uh the ratio between the highest and the
smallest
singular values so what's this can you
prove it like in a black box way from
cusco by showing that
if you have this robust condition number
then when you add the air
you still have the original version of
cusco one large or is that not
sorry if you this is a stronger
condition right right no so
i guess one theorem you could prove that
maybe then would reduce it to
this concept is that if you have a
kl tower large then when you add error
the original kr is still large is that
what you prove or no no no
the error goes to t not to the yeah
exactly
so i should make one more uh one more
remark
you know you could examine chris carl's
proof and say
all right how can you actually come up
with a robust version of chris carl's
group
and at least the the most direct ways in
which we
thought about doing this it seemed to us
that you would need exponentially small
error
in order to make the calculation work so
in other words what would happen is
whatever
input error you have the output error
would be
larger by an exponential factor what
this means
sorry yeah there is an inductive proof
and
uh you the error blows up in that in
that process
and uh this would mean that in terms of
sample complexity you would need
exponential number of samples in order
to identify these things yeah
so this crucial condition is
fairly standard in algebraic geometry
it's that if you think of these
um points these k points they're in
what's called general
linear position that is say no three lie
on a line
no four line up two plane etc all the
way up to k
planes so is your um
condition number condition
sort of saying that there that no
no three points are close to being on a
line in in some
very precise way yes basically that's
what it is right yeah
this is that's basically what the
condition is saying
so what is always
that is always a major problem you're
dealing with
so so do these things
if the rank and border rank are
different you never have unique
decomposition for rank
so in particular this means that in this
range the
border rank equals the rank if the
hypotheses of the theorem are satisfied
yeah
that's an assurance but also uh you know
this robust risk
rank implies something for border rank
as well
this overall confusion in the statement
sorry
in theory you cannot recover a b and c
exactly because you have this error
so how do you compute the crystal rank
sub tau of a
since you don't have it no so as i said
before
we don't have a method to certify
critical rank
right and similarly we don't have a
method to certify
crystal rank tab of a or to verify right
what we're saying is that
if you had a tensor that you were trying
to decompose and if you
knew by some other means that this
guarantee holds
then this thing would work right so now
what this means is that if you're trying
to decompose you know a mixture of
gaussians or some kind of hidden marker
model or something
it implies some condition that should
hold on the parameters of your hidden
mark
okay but we don't have any way to
actually verify this condition
yeah so to your condition on this robust
crystal rank is sort of not
invented under scaling right under these
linear factors that you could
exchange between a b and c
uh well
no it's it is right what do you mean
right as in
given a matrix if you scale
a vector i say yes
true true true so you could imagine that
okay i will pick the best scalings
amongst yes
amongst each other yeah say you have the
best
best at scaling or sorry you know how to
do
how
no so what we're saying is that if we
are given a tensor
with abc where abc satisfies this
condition we're not actually trying to
find the best search scaling
then this right so
you know similarly to the fact that we
don't really know how to
even certify what the crystal rank is
we're not actually going to try to find
the best scaling and so on
okay you said the condition number
wasn't ratio right
no no but if you just kill one guy then
it changes right
well question was the following that you
know we said
the when you look at tens of
decomposition you can multiply
the a i b i c i by scalar so that they
multiply
product as one so you could averagely
scale one guy and scale down the other
fellows
but this could have a very bad effect on
the
robust coloring
extensions of the nuclear norm
regularization whatever to the tensor
case
how does this condition compare yes i'm
not sure i know what recovery conditions
are you know based on
things about i mean at least
superficially
so does it apply to tensors directly
versions i mean there's more general
versions that just
okay so i'm not sure i know i'm not sure
i know how the you know
what the conditions are when you look at
those okay
all right uh
so let me i'm not going to tell you what
the proof of this is i'll actually focus
on something else for most of the talk
but just some comments on what this what
this means as i said
because our blow up in error is
polynomial this means that
with the polynomial number of samples we
can actually decompose
tensors
and in general they are very
the few results went on tensor
decompositions when abc are not full
rank
uh and this this gives you something for
that case as well
okay um all right one
big drawback of all of this is that
both kruskal's result and our result are
not constructed
right so we have a proof of uniqueness
but it doesn't actually give you an
algorithm
um there are algorithms known for
certain cases
for the so-called full rank case where
two of a b and c have rank r
and actually we'll see this this
algorithm in a little bit
in general finding tensor decompositions
are known to be hard problems in fact
hasta showed in 88 that finding tensor
rank is hard
hilar and limb in 2008 showed that
almost all denser problems are in fact
that's the title of their paper yeah
sorry so tau and air have no relation to
each other in other words air could be
so large compared to tau
that by the time you do the error
perturbation your crystal conditions
completely
is that possible uh
no no no so uh you know in the
dependence on error prime
the connection between error prime and
error there will be some dependence on
top
but air could be arbitrarily large
compared to top there's no restriction
on how large air can be
but then maybe you'll get meaningless
yeah it's not clear right if
you would get meaningless stuff
presumably because because you've
destroyed crystal condition completely
yeah and you can drive the point is you
can drive this error down
as long as this is a empirical average
of from your data
you can drive the error down just by
taking more samples
so that was the point the point is that
we can choose error to be sufficiently
small so
that even with this blow up this new
error is meaningful it gives you some
information in some sense the way you
think about it is that you're given a
prime and tau
and then you compute how many samples
you need your computer and you know how
many samples you need
yes exactly you got to go backwards so
yes
what are these algorithms effective or
no they're not
oh sorry which one these well you said
algorithms known only for fluorine case
are those effective algorithms or
they're just
sort of the polynomial algorithms we'll
see one of them
they're polynomials yeah
and these are actually very old
algorithms uh
i mean the earliest one that we know is
uh dates back to work of harshman
which two in turn was analyzing an
algorithm
uh i forgot the uh i think it's it's
close to the
either 60
smaller than n i think because use
eigenvectors
yes yes it works in the case when r is
less than n well that's implicit right
because a
two of them have to have full rank they
can only have rank up two in it
yeah right the rank can be at most n
when i say that the rank is
r then r can be at one stand okay
in general finding tensor decompositions
is hard
and there's an open problem that
actually has some money attached to it
um can we get an effective version of
crystal serum can we get an algorithmic
version
of this class here
one-fourth of that money is mine now
uh okay so so let me turn now to the
algorithmic aspect i talked about
uh you know just this uniqueness and
identifiability and so on
let me turn to the algorithms so before
we
talk about algorithms let's go back and
review you know
in what situations we encounter tensor
decompositions
for learning problems so as i said
before
there's an assumption that some kind of
model is generating data
you know in fact you have some model
maybe it's documents or whatever
you hypothesize that the data is
actually produced by some kind of model
and then you try to learn the parameters
of this model right
okay so let me talk about two kinds of
models one is learning a mixture of
gaussians which many of you must have
seen before if not
you've certainly been reminded on day
one
you have r gaussians the means are mu1
u2 mu r they have mixing weights w1 to
wr
sum up to and data is generated in the
following way
you pick a gaussian with probability wi
having picked the ith gaussian you
sample a point from this gaussian
can you repeat this process many times
that's your data given
this ensemble of points you'd like to
reverse engineer and figure out what
these means were and what these mixing
weights were and so on so forth
okay another kind of model also that we
saw on day one
uh is a simple topic model for documents
um you know given a corpus we'd like to
attach some kind of meaning we like to
figure out what documents are about and
so on so forth
so the hypothesis is that every document
is about a topic and for now
pretend that every document is about a
single topic
each topic could be thought of as a
property distribution over words
um so our model is the following there
are
r probability vectors pr these
correspond to the probability
distributions for each of the topics we
have mixing weights w1 to wr
and the way in which a document
degenerate generates the following you
pick
a topic that's probably proportional to
wr
and then you pick words from the
document
with probably proportional to the pro
with probabilities given by the the
probability vector for that particular
topic okay
example many such words that's your
document right
because this is not really how documents
are generated but this is the hypothesis
and then you try to find the best
setting of parameters that fits your
model
all right so what's the general recipe
the recipe is what i said before right
we're going to
take each of these problems and somehow
reduce it to some kind of density
composition problem
how do we do that we compute a certain
tensor whose decomposition encodes these
model parameters
and then we try to find this
decomposition okay
so for gaussian mixtures
it turns out that roughly speaking we
can
estimate this particular tensor so
the sum over all the components
the mixing weight times the tensor
product
of the mean so mu r tensor mu r tensor
this this takes some work you've got to
do some cancellations and so on but
basically you can estimate this tensor
okay so this is the n by n by n can we
do this
when you know they're not spherical so
this is yeah under some conditions right
you can actually handle the
non-spherical uh no
this is all spherical yes yes yes this
is all spectrum right so
i'm i'm hiding all these caveats under
the rug
so can you say again what this tensor is
i mean i don't
so suppose you have means mu mu1 mu to
mu r
right this is the
sum of the tensor products of the means
right so
you're looking at the earth mean
tensored three times
summed over all the components what does
this represent or
what how does this come up well for
example
how do you produce it how did this arise
oh how does it rise okay so
so remember the gaussian mixture model
that we had before yes
you have data that's generated according
to from this probability distribution
so roughly speaking for every point that
you get
right if you compute um
say x tensor x tends or x sum it up
you expect to get a term like this so
why do you stop at three
you can go higher you can also go higher
right uh now one problem with with
gaussians is that you don't just get
this term you also get some other stuff
which i'm hiding here turns out
in some of those cases you can remove
these additional terms
one problem with going to higher terms
higher order tensors
with gaussians in particular is you know
it's just
hairier to deal with all these
additional terms that you get so you
have to worry about these additional
terms and so on
so that doesn't outweigh the uniqueness
getting better
uh so for example in the topic model
case it's much easier to
compute higher order tensors there we
don't have this problem and yes we can
go to higher order tensors
in fact as you'll see you know
eventually when i talk about our results
we're not going to talk about three
tensors at all we're going to talk about
higher order tensors
so the issue with going to higher order
tensors is one of complexity
obviously the algorithms take longer the
sample complexity is
is higher but you can typically deal
with
a much higher rank so there are
advantages and disadvantages
okay all right so for gaussian mixtures
roughly speaking we can compute this
tensor
right and i said how we compute it we
compute it from the data you've got to
do some corrections but forget about
that don't worry about it
similarly for the topic model case you
can estimate this tensor
where instead of the muse you have these
probability vectors
tensor three times that's it and instead
of three tens or you can compute four
tens or five trends or six tens or
whatever you want
okay and the goal
is given these tensors that you've
estimated you want to figure out what
these news are yeah
so for for these particular models or
any others that we're used to in certain
methods
um were identifiability conditions known
without these
critical type tensor theorems or is this
like the first time we we have good
identifiability conditions for these
models
so gaussian mixtures for example have
been studied for a long time
and uh you know the the kinds of results
that we
we knew typically were based on the
separation between the means
okay so one kind of result says that if
you have
k gaussians and the means are
separated enough right i have to tell
you what enough means
um then given a mixed
given data from this picture of gaussian
i can actually recover the means
but there is no question in for
identifiability that's not a problem
yeah if identifiably identifiability
well
you also need some separation with the
means beyond that
the problem is not uniquely identified
given given that right now the proof of
crystal's theorem is not algorithmic
like identifiability is what we should
be worrying about here right
that's all that crystal's giving us so
you're okay within some examples
under infinite samples and a very very
generic conditions inside it
okay okay we're actually
moved away from identifiability we want
to try to produce algorithms now
so i'm going to try to talk about
algorithms
but yes so there were algorithms known
for mixtures of gaussians and so on in
slightly different regimes
what's nice about these tensor methods
is that they give you
results you know without any separation
assumptions and so on so forth
which we didn't know how to do before
okay
all right so as i said before you know
one big problem with this entire
framework is that
we reduced a problem that we didn't know
how to do this learning problem
to this tensor problem and produce
presumably would reduce to a very hard
problem right
because we don't know how to solve these
kinds of problems and they're all these
worst case hardness results
the key point though is that these
hardness results are in the worst case
these np hardness results and so on say
that if you want to solve tensor
decomposition in general there's no hope
unless p equals np okay
now if you think about the kinds of
instances that arise
for which we would like to solve these
problems you could you could say well
are these really worst case instances
so you know i i said for gaussian
mixtures you have a tensor like this for
topic models you have a tensor like this
nature is not really conspiring against
you to give you inputs that make your
algorithm look bad
so presumably we should be able to do
something for
typical instances of course the question
is what
two typical instances mean what what are
they really
um so we'll take inspiration from smooth
analysis it was introduced by spielmann
and tang
that should be o1 um
and uh i'll explain to you what i mean
by applying smooth analysis for tensory
compositions
okay so we're going to move away from
worst case instances and say that
if our tensors came from a certain
smooth model can we hope to learn them
it can be can we produce decomposition
algorithms
for such tensors right
okay so here's our tensor let's say
three tensor
and you know just to remind ourselves
these are what typical instances look
like
now instead of assuming that these
components a b and c are worst case
remember
a b and c are for example means of
gaussians or the probability vectors
associated with various topics
what kind of assumption we could make is
that these components abc are random
okay that's a very strong assumption and
hopefully well it should be possible to
do something for that but
it wouldn't be very satisfying what
would be much
nicer is if we had something that sort
of interpolates between
worst case and average case so not
completely random
but has some elements of worst case
that's what smooth analysis allows us to
do
so the assumption is the following
imagine that your components abc
are produced in the following way right
so you you take worst case factor
you take arbitrary sets of vectors a is
b i c i
and now for each of them you add a
little perturbation
okay and that is your input your input
is the tensor product of these perturbed
vectors
okay so the assumption is that somehow
you know the means of these gaussians or
these probability vectors
associate documents are not in some
worst case configuration
so if you if you had a mixture of
gaussians
then i guess there's some samples you
can do where the
expected value of those samples is that
tensor but do the fluctuations around it
look like this or would they no so the
assumption is the following right
um you had a mixture of gaussians
i'm going to assume that your mixture of
gaussians
was not the means were not in a worst
case configuration
yeah they were actually produced in the
following way
you know there was there was some worst
case that you had in mind let's say
but then i jiggle them a little bit i
move them a little bit those were your
means you produce your entire data
according to these perturb me
and that's what i have to work with okay
perturbed yes all your estimates are of
these already perturbed
right so these perturbations are not
errors
right they're just some uh natural
variability in these instances
which helps us prove that for typical
instances produced from this
distribution
uh we're not going to have all these
much harder
yeah so right you know one assumption
would be
assume that your inputs are completely
random this is a much more nuanced
notion of randomness right it says that
you know somewhere pretty much around
every point in your space
there is a very dense set pretty much
all the instances that you
look in a little sphere around that that
point are tractable
so i just it it differs does it differ
from other types of smooth analysis in
that in some other cases
if you're given a worst case input you
could choose to add a little bit of
noise to it
perturb it but here it's not obvious
that you can do that right
yeah so i mean the wayne spielman and
tang applied this to
uh linear programming was that they said
well imagine you have a linear
programming problem
yeah but you know how are the
constraints produced
they're not so start with arbitrary
constraints
yeah and now perturb the coefficients a
little bit yeah that's your linear
program that's the one you'd like to
solve
and they analyze simplex for that
particular thing yeah
justice spin didn't give a strongly
polynomial time algorithm for solving
linear programs so so moses is not
giving
and algorithm for the worst case field
wait does this version of the animation
is that identical with what you're
saying
well you could i mean it makes perfect
sense to to do
what you just described from 310
take the tensor slightly
this is what you're trying to do
no we're not doing that right
you have a tensor you perturb it
slightly
the issue is these kinds of
perturbations
are very different from those kinds of
perturbations your
the performance you're proposing are
basically noise
right and uh we can deal with these
easily uh
in general it's much easier to argue
about about these kinds of things
but the trouble is you're not
fundamentally you're not changing what
these
a's b's and c's are they're still the
same so
in that sense we cannot handle what you
know
if i could then i would be able to
decompose general tensors right
i don't know that this is not true so i
mean they they
for me the the the way i'm thinking
about smoothness is that
in the space of all possible inputs to
get the problem
because there are no bad instances at
all they cannot rule out the possibility
of
the phenomenon but if there are if they
exist
they're very isolated they're a very
discreet sense in the sense that
anywhere i'm almost repeating the words
that you said before if you
move random to a small distance
with almost certainty you you're landing
in a good place for a
decent algorithm the one that they
analyzed
works so that this is a very satisfying
situation so i wonder if you know what
is the story here
we know that this is true is it possibly
true
uh i would imagine this is not
going to be true so okay so
if this were true okay so if this were
true for low rank tensors right
so if you have a low rank tensor and you
add a little bit of noise and suddenly
the problem becomes
easier then by identifiability result
whatever no decomposition you get of
this noisy tensor would
be close to the decomposition of the
original tensor
okay you're moving away from a low
dimensional thing
yeah and maybe there's an algorithm for
low
for low ranked uh tensors but
these hardness results by the way
typically apply to much higher rank
ranked like n squared yeah sorry a quick
remark i mean a clarification right
smooth analysis cannot help solve worst
case problems i mean linear programming
is the worst
but it becomes completely different
stays here presumably
yes i mean you just said if you have a
lower side but it will become full rank
potential right
so it's a different problem yeah but
it's saying the different problem might
be easier that's all it's saying right
that's all it can say i suppose smoke
yeah
but also the point i was trying to make
is that this perturbation that we have
is
you should assume that your model has
this perturbation built into it
right this is not something that the
algorithm does the algorithm could do it
but it won't help the algorithm in the
worst case i mean there's nothing
preventing the algorithm from doing
development but you would never generate
these kind of correlated perturbations
that so
you're saying these individual vectors
rather than the tensor
is that the difference you're making
yeah because it makes sense right
what are these individual vectors these
individual vectors are really the the
model parameters
right so you could assume that the model
parameters are not in a worst case
situation
right and that's basically what this
assumption is saying so
they're arbitrary plus some little
perturbation
mathematically is order n independent
random variables yeah or
n cubed it's not yeah yes yes you're
right
so i must say i'm really impressed
when i first first came here before i
looked through the schedule i thought it
was a 45 minute talk so
one thing that is very suggestive when
you think about this from the point of
view
i'm now talking more or less under my
head as a
bioinformatician people really when they
they were really interested in looking
for a high dimensional
analogue festival which is so
but essentially they there is no such
thing in hybrid mentions
and i wonder if this there's no analog
of spd in higher dimensions
everything that you could think breaks
you know the notion of
set being not cloned
thought okay
all right in the in the interest of
moving forward
um i should also mention that
this smooth model that we came up with
was also considered
pretty much in parallel by another group
of people anderson belkin goes
rajamanpur was i'll say a little bit
about their results
um they considered a similar model they
applied it to
learning gaussians and so on the the
nature of the results that we have
are slightly different and i'll
elaborate on that later
okay so uh i mentioned that there are
algorithms for tensor composition in
certain cases okay
at high level we're going to fall back
on these well-known algorithms we don't
produce a new algorithm
we're just going to fall back on this
whole algorithm so i should tell you
what this whole algorithm does
okay so so here's the algorithm
so you have this tensor uh
sum of rank one terms um
what these algorithms basically say is
that um
if two of a and b two of these
matrices abc are full rank then we can
recover this tensor
okay and let me tell you how you can do
this
okay so one comment going forward
you know these kinds of algorithms
there's no hope to do them
in the so-called over complete case when
the number of rank one terms that you
have
the rank of the tensor is much larger
than n
you cannot hope to do this in fact hard
instances the known np hardness and so
on
uh they do have high rank it's precisely
these overcomplete cases
where all of our algorithms fail okay so
these are the cases that you would like
to produce new algorithms for and we
don't know how to do that
okay all right so
uh so let me tell you about this
generics algorithm which
goes back several decades the starting
point of this is the following so
suppose i have two matrices that have a
common diagonalization
i have m1 which is x d1 y transpose and
m2 is
x d2 y transpose so both m1 and m2 are
linear combinations of
you know x i tensor
y i but with different coefficients
coefficients are given by these diagonal
matrices d1 and d2
the claim is that if d1 and d2 are
sufficiently different
and i'm not going to elaborate how
different then basically we can recover
x and y
how do we recover x and y for example
you compute m1 m2 inverse
from this you can recover x uh
and similarly you can compute m2 m1
inverse from that you can recover y
and then you can pair up the x and y
okay
so very simple algorithm what does this
have to do with tensor decomposition
well if we look at the tensor okay
let's uh let's look at the s
slice of the tensor i'm slicing
according to this
more second one s
slice of this term is basically a i
outer product c i with some coefficient
the coefficient is given by
the s coefficient of the vector bi
right so the point is this if you look
at all of the slices of the tensor they
basically have a common diagonalization
just the coefficients that multiply
these terms are different right
so presumably we can apply this previous
algorithm
to learn the a and the c vectors
having learned the a and c vectors we
can learn b that's the basic idea
so you could almost run this just by
looking at two slices that doesn't quite
work what you actually do is you take
two random combinations of the slices
this these two random combinations are
matrices that have a common
diagonalization
you learn the vectors a and c from that
and then from that you recover v
okay so that's the algorithm um
so in fact this algorithm has been
rediscovered many times
you know basically algorithms with a
similar approach have been used over the
years in similar applications
in work that appeared slightly before
ours goele vampala and xiao actually
analyzed this algorithm and showed that
this is like
also robust to noise this is a good
algorithm to use
okay so we're going to fall back on this
algorithm all right
but i said there's a problem here right
remember um
i'd like to produce algorithms that work
for very high rank
so when the number of gaussians we have
is very large
the number of top topics we have is very
large and so on so forth
this is a fundamental limitation this is
never going to recover more than n terms
okay so how could we possibly
apply this algorithm when we have high
rank
well that's another
there's other work that was presented in
this uh workshop which suggested that
this algorithm is not robust to noise
and that's why you would result resort
something like a tensor power method
is there a reason why
i mean i don't necessarily believe that
i'm just not saying is there a reason
why
you prefer this one is it as a matter of
convenience over over a power method or
so you need different kinds of
assumptions when you look at the
tensorflow method
to work so for example you need some
kind of
incoherence assumptions and so on so
you know one drawback of using our
methods is that
they're not going to give you practical
algorithms right so this is more sort of
a complexity theoretic view of the
problem
why as you'll see we're going to need
you know uh higher order tensors
and the sample complexity is going to
depend you know it's going to be
polynomial and so and so forth but it'll
the dependence on you know the order of
the tensor will be pretty bad
so in that sense it's not you know those
algorithms are probably much more
practical those are things that you
might want to use in practice
but they typically need stronger
assumptions on the data and we're going
to try to make we're making much weaker
assumptions on the data
um this kind of smooth assumption says
very little about incoherence
so that's what so you know you you lose
some you make stronger assumptions and
you you get much better much practical
algorithms
still differently because
they have this common diagonalization
and you try to
compute maybe i'm doing this some kind
of our method
i mean wouldn't
well i didn't say anything about these
vectors ais and ci right and they could
uh they could be roughly in the same
direction and then
you know power method like things won't
work very well
i guess if like the if you implement the
algorithm like you would you know
when you have to you know diagonalize
this
you have to invert the other guy before
yeah
maybe you should ask the authors
okay all right let me get back and try
to finish
on time a little bit over time okay so
here's the basic idea i said
look we have a large number of terms but
we don't have enough dimensions
we have dimension n so what we're going
to do is
instead of our n-dimensional vectors
we're going to produce higher
dimensional vectors
and hope and pray that these vectors are
in fact
linearly independent so we show that
these vectors are linearly independent
how do we do this instead of computing a
three tensor you know how about
computing a six tensor remember this
data came from
some model and we computed moments and
so instead of computing
third moments how about six moments okay
we can compute as high moments as we
want
so let's look at six points now what
we're going to do is
we're going to combine
these two modes these two modes and
these two modes
and think of this as a n square
dimensional vector this is an n squared
dimensional vector and this was an n
squared
okay so this is a three tensor
consisting of n square dimensional
vectors
and now we have some hope that perhaps
these vectors are full rank
okay the original vectors ais were not
necessarily for rank
but once we take tensor product in this
way we could hope that the resulting
vectors are in fact
full right okay so that's what we're
going to do
we're going to compute a high order
tensor we're going to do this flattening
we're going to
collapse several modes into one uh
and now we're going to apply the three
tensor algorithm
provided we can guarantee that we have
the rank condition that we need
okay so that's the question
if i have these arbitrary vectors ais
with these little gaussian perturbations
can i prove or is it true that these
vectors are linearly independent
okay so if you don't remember anything
else with this talk this is a nice
geometric nugget
that i'd like you to take back uh
in fact you know as you might suspect
the answer is yes
a proof of this fact is fairly messy
uh i'd like to think that there might be
a much simpler more elegant proof
it'd be very nice to prove this in a
much simpler way
okay so let me tell you how
our proof works roughly so you know some
of the problems are trying to prove a
result like this
and these vectors have an inherent block
structure
right uh in terms of the perturbation
that you have
perturbation is is actually very
correlated as ravi pointed out that
there is uh
you know you have an n dimensional
gaussian that's added to each of these
and you produce an n square dimensional
vector so you have much little
you don't have as much randomness as you
would like
um and what we prove informally is that
given any sets of vectors the a's and
the b's
if you apply this perturbation let's say
the number of vectors is less than n
square over four
with probably one minus exponential in
minus square root n
let's say this perturbation is good
these these vectors are
linearly independent also the condition
number is good and so on
um all right this also applies to higher
order
higher order products but for this talk
we'll just talk about
uh products of two vectors yeah so a
very simple question so what are the n
squared and
n squared vectors that that will show
that have good condition number
ai times br and not yet atoms
you're not doing them as a times b i
yeah
but you can also apply it to i mean if
you remember
our tensor was mu i tensor mu i tends to
mui so it's the same vector mu i
we do some partitioning coordinates to
pretend that these are different vectors
a and b okay
how much time do i have actually since
um
basically lots of questions what do you
say
running five minutes sorry how long do
you want to go
a little bit i don't know as long as
you're willing to sit
i think you're ready okay all right five
minutes
okay so let me try to give you a very
very brief overview of how this
how this proof works um
okay so as i said you know a problem
improving a result like this is that our
perturbations are
very correlated um and the main
technical contribution i said the
then you know the one technical nugget
i'd like to take back is
is proof that these products of
perturbed vectors in fact
behave like random vectors okay
in n square dimensions in what sense
so here's the strategy what we're going
to try to prove is that
every such product perturbed product
has large projection onto the space
that's orthogonal to the
span of the rest okay
if we can prove this we're done
basically this is what we need to prove
this will imply
a bound in the condition number and so
on so forth so each of these vectors
has large projection on the space or
thousand of the span of the rest
problem is you know the space of these
remaining guys
is also some kind of random space it was
produced by this perturbation and so we
don't really have a good handle on what
the space
is okay but instead of trying to say
that it's
it has a large projection onto that
space we know that the space is
n square over four dimensional right
space orthogonal is three and square
over four dimensions we'll say that
this has large production on to any
three n square over four okay
even less than that so you're saying
that yeah
so we'll say that this has large
production onto any three n square four
dimensional in particular it must have
lost projection onto
that particular space all right
so uh now the proof of this
involves a certain construction i'm not
going to be able to tell you very many
details of the
of the construction i should say one
thing um
if you use results on anti-concentration
of polynomials
you can get such a result which will
succeed with probably one minus one of a
polynomial
okay so the failure probability will be
one more polynomial one of our
challenges was
we were trying to get error probability
which was somehow exponential
okay and at least it seems to us that
that shooting for this kind of
exponential error probably seems to need
much more delicate proofs i said this
would be very nice result to prove if
there was a simple
proof of this we'd be very interested
okay
roughly speaking we show the following
so in any
3n square over 4 dimensional space
there are some special there are some
root n vectors
m1 m2 m root n now remember that this 3n
square over 4 dimensional space is a
space of
n by n matrices
so viewed as an n by n matrix
these m1 m2 m root n have a
special block structure okay
and the rough property is that you know
if you look at the eighth column it has
enough projection
orthogonal to the remaining columns
i'm not really saying this very well i'm
not really being very precise
but this is the kind of structure that
we're looking for we're looking for
special vectors m one m two m root n in
any three n square over four dimensional
which have some nice orthogonality
properties
and we show that we can actually do this
and this is the crux of the construction
i'll be happy to say more uh if you if
you guys would like to hear more
all right so you know similar result
holds for higher dimensions
uh you have to be a little more careful
when you're dealing with not two tensors
but higher tensors
so okay let me tell you what the main
result is the main result basically says
for higher order tensors we can
in the sense of smooth analysis we can
compute decompositions for rank that
goes up to n to the d minus one over two
okay that's what we get out of this uh
forget about the technical statement
there's some dependence on you know if
you look at
d tensors what's the exponential as a
function of d
and so on and so forth but let's ignore
that
most likely n to the d over two is looks
like
like an algorithmic upper bound right
yes
although i don't know if there are any
formal results showing something
uh i guess here i was talking about what
is the
right you could you could talk about the
rank how high a rank you can hope to get
on this i presume end of the day over
two seems to be limited
seems like a number we make up a bound
but i don't think there is any
kind of result that says it
yeah i'm not sure
okay uh let me finish so this also
applies to all these mixture models and
so on provides results for those
i'm not going to tell you what the
precise results are let me just contrast
with this other paper that i mentioned
by anderson at all
so they get very similar results to what
we get as i said we
get exponential probability of failure
probability this is the kind of failure
perplexer we get
they get polynomial error failure
probability
the sample complexity is polynomial in n
and one over rho
our sample complexity is also polynomial
the one key point is that um
the exponent of this polynomial in our
case is exponential and d
and the exponent of the problem in that
case is polynomial and d something like
d squared
so the problems are a little bit
different somehow shooting for really
small error probability
seems to make at least our proofs much
more complicated
okay let me stop with some open problems
uh
it'd be very nice to get robust
uniqueness for ranks which are bigger
than
n asymptotically bigger than n and some
members of the audience have
shown that decompositions are typically
unique up to n square over 16 we
discussed this
very early in the talk can we actually
get robust analogs of these results we
don't know
um some of these methods come from
algebraic geometry and
at least i we don't have a good way to
understand
you know whether or not they can you can
produce robust analogs of those
in general trying to decompose beyond
rank n is a big challenge
just for three dancers can we decompose
under crisco's conditions
can we prove hardness in this regime we
don't really know
and some results of anema wrong
and why did it show that
decomposition is possible in some cases
you can do this for ranks which are
constant times n
but they need some some sort of
incoherence assumptions on there
um finally there's a dependence on error
i mean the kinds of error that we can
tolerate in these methods is really tiny
it's polynomial
inverse polynomial n one question is do
these mothers completely failed if the
error is constant
there's some hope that we might be able
to do something
those regimes results of uh was david
and john
show that certain kinds of tensor
decomposition problems when
attacked with this tool of sum of
squares relaxations
do yield even under constant error so
that would be a nice that's a promising
direction
first okay thank you thank you for your
patience
any more questions
i understand that your technique for
even
numbers so for example for seats say
you're gonna go two to two
but assume you have a five right exactly
we don't need six
i just put put it there to be symmetric
uh
what i said will work with five right
you you only need
two of the modes to have full rank
and for the other one you just need
crystal rank two
so uh so in fact
we will do it we do it for odd numbers
in fact
uh i mean the six was just for
convenience so i didn't have to
you know confuse you by saying that we
combined two more than two ones only one
again